we are seeing ad rates dropping a lot
really yeah we're seeing these these
layoffs in Silicon Valley before svb
yeah this news came out all the tech
layoffs yeah I'm looking at in our ad
right so I'm just like be a member
because membership is a shield for us
and then with with ads dropping the way
they are this time of year it feels like
it's going to be a summer of a very very
dark Financial days now we're seeing
this look I don't want to be I don't
want to say something that could
precipitate it by encouraging people to
Panic or anything like that I'm just
saying
I I agree with you that the world is the
neolib neocon system is breaking apart
that means the night is always darkest
before the dawn I tell people to get
some chickens and get some emergency
food and learn how to take care of that
I tell the people first thing is when a
guy look this is madness this the
economic system we have today is madness
when Biden sits there as as when you
look at the depression of working-class
people in this country and they come up
this week everything we've been talking
about and they come up with uh 6.8
trillion dollar budget not one cut to
one program in fact the rate of increase
I think is almost six percent a 5.2
percent pay increase for federal
employees and across the board they have
they have at their own calculation what
train and half dollar deficits as far as
the aggregate the three trillion dollar
taxes which I my recommendation is the
house should meet tomorrow and Saturday
the Republicans they should pass every
tax increase they've got all of them
send it to the Schumer and the Democrats
and dare them to pass it you're gonna
see what phonies they are because it's
all their donors all the big hedge fund
guys are are their donors all the owners
all the billionaires are their donors
those billionaires hate Maga right and
then and by the way Schumer had the guts
to do it which you wouldn't do it Biden
would veto it because it's all his all
his sponsors
no I'm for more than the wealth tax when
you have one wealth tax I'm more than
that no I want the briefs I want the
repatriation look when you have one
percent of the people citizens own more
Assets in the bottom 90. that system
can't sustain itself greed if the
Revolutionary generation came back they
would spit on the floor they fought a
revolution to get away from a landed
aristocracy and the mercantilist system
of the monopolies of the British East
India Company and others like it that's
what John Adams and Sam Adams and
Hancock were Smugglers the rest were
smart lawyers they said we want our own
deal we're not going to do that if they
came back and said you guys allowed this
to devolve into an oligarchy are you
kidding me we're one percent of the
people this is exactly what they fought
the revolution for it was like believe
in the elites even among the
revolutionaries yeah there was a sense
of Duty yes that was expected exactly
and that's what we lack today and I
don't know how you guys I don't know how
you reignite that sense of patriotism I
feel like I think I think the way I
think the way you do it is what you guys
did in the first week of of uh of uh uh
January
but even that when you had everybody in
conservative media against you when you
had Fox News against you we had oh it's
unity and you guys are terrible guys and
I gotta tell you we came that close on
that Friday night at 10 o'clock to Total
Victory right it was that it was hung in
the balance so it's it's
I think people get patriarch when they
see that when they see action they love
their country go out in the hinterland
in your constituents they're so far
ahead of where we are it's not stupid
they understand the details they
understand what's going on because
there's shows like uh Tim pool and so
many other podcasts out there that get
the information out to people and
they're hungry for information they will
immerse themselves if you put up
different links to go to they will I
give homework assignments over the
weekend people will read it and come
back and it'll be informed and be asking
questions in the chat rooms Etc so
people want the patriotism the DNA of
our Revolution is still with us right
right it's still with us remember
there's only a third of the guys in the
in the revolution on our side right
there's a third Tories a third of
ourselves and a third in the middle like
there always is to say hey I'm gonna see
how this thing plays out that's the
resilience of the country the resilience
exactly they can take institutions over
but they can't really change that the
people can step forward and do it fix
something when they're ready to do it it
sounds like Occupy Wall Street you know
and I think the reason critically
had a lot of positive stuff with it
between before it went off the tracks
listen you can't have a systems
yes no the good parts is you can't have
this concentration listen Obama remember
Obama ran as a anti-war populist to
defeat Hillary Clinton right something
Bernie Sanders didn't do in Two Shots on
goal okay he ran anti-war populace when
he came in with he inherited this
financial collapse and quite frankly did
the neoliberal way to just flood the
Zone take the federal reserve's balance
sheet put four trillion dollars on it
flood the zone to boost up uh assets of
real estate and and stocks and bonds go
to negative interest rates so the little
guy gets screwed they did they debated
it the the minutes of the president of
the governors of the of the Federal
Reserve dick Fisher down in Dallas he
walked through how you are doing this
bailout on the backs of working class
and middle class people who have no
chance for Capital formation their
savings accounts their checkings
accounts their money market accounts are
going to have nothing and 10 years from
now they're literally going to have
nothing except what they work for which
were taxing at essentially a 40 rate
they're going to have nothing until we
vote on the Silicon Valley Bank bailout
I was I'm so sure that they can do
something like that I mean they got you
know it's like you said well you have
the tools or we're going to admire them
we're going to use them I don't think
they can do I don't think they can go
bail out well I tell you how
predicted on Timmy no vote no no no but
tell them
by the way you said today tell them how
they're going to do it they're going to
use National Security and they're going
to use the Deep State as the excuse that
that Gates nailed today early in our
show they're going to say that this is
the centerpiece of all these companies
that are high-tech companies in Silicon
Valley all these companies that let us
compete with the Chinese and if you
don't let them make payroll next week
okay it's going to collapse and we're
going to be a decade behind the CCP and
they're going to make it and make it
announced so what's the Coalition of
votes there the Silicon Valley Democrats
led by rokana the neoconservatives uh
led by the traditional voices of that
movement in in the house Republican
caucus and then the appropriators
because they always you know they
spending money is not typically
something that's an affront to someone
on the Appropriations Committee is that
is that the the co that's the Coalition
that looks like 400 that looks like 400
votes a lot more votes than I got on my
my resolution to pull out of Syria I
don't see that Coalition coming together
I don't see rokahana as much as he talks
about economic patriotism putting that
Coalition together to have a bailout of
of East Palestine Ohio see we're gonna
you guys are going to replay 2008 and
2009 where Louis garment you had you had
a decision do we step in and have
intervention and try to save this
corrupt system by infusing it with
taxpayer cash to bail out the elites or
do we let the contagion spread and let
the devil catch the hindmost and the
problem is when you're looking into the
abyss it's a very tough call for you
guys to make because they're going to
sit there and go right now we're looking
into an open pit you have no idea how
deep this could go you know how the
American Financial system could collapse
how the International Financial system
collapse so you better vote to bail it
out with taxpayer cash so you're going
to take it from people making forty five
thousand dollars a year to bail out the
wealthiest people on Earth and they're
going to put a gun to your head and
they're going to say okay you're gonna
you you if you don't if you vote no and
let but capitalism take its take its
take its path this contagion will spread
they're already talking about is it a
contagion or chemotherapy that's what
I'm trying to say yes are you saying let
svb fail
I think you have to by the way until you
get a bailout of East Palestine Ohio
screw screw look those people are the
guys that mock and ridicule Maga every
day of the week this is the elite that
is it's an elite Bank the mo I think
most elite Bank in the country it only
has a certain clientele of the only the
best of these high-tech companies only
it's all the Venture capitalists it's uh
politically they all hate us and they
they Mock and ridicule the central part
of this country the the the coastal
Elites let their venture capital from
they got plenty of cash plenty of
capital let them go bail themselves out
physician heal thyself do not come to us
when you have not you sit there and you
Mock and ridicule East Palestine you
have some bogus uh
um a hearing when nothing gets settled
nothing gets sorted until East Palestine
gets a bailout there shouldn't be one
freaking penny I'm given to anything in
Silicon Valley I agree and it feels
similar to the energy I felt when when
you guys stood it up in the speaker's
vote Yes someone finally saying to the
machine you can't just steamroll us over
and over and over the same Play It's
2008 nine it's it's the
it is exactly exactly exactly what's
going to happen I don't know that to
what extent if you go back to town halls
if you go back to town halls in your
District
next week next weekend so we'll say
they've come to us with svb and we're
going to lose here's we're going to lose
the contagion is going to spread to
other Banks number two we're going to
lose all these great companies uh and
we're going to be lose all our
Innovation for a decade that's what
we're saying we're going to lose all
Innovation for a decade what is your
what is your District going to tell you
if a an earthquake hit Silicon Valley
I'm not sure that my constituents would
vote to send FEMA so with the banks
failing they certainly won't be won't be
in favor of sending their money he's the
master wow that's so great I I am uh
the part of me fears the ripple effect
on regular people part of me feels like
rip the Band-Aid off you cannot have
this moral hazard you simply cannot and
you know what Bannon told you moments
ago regular people are going to get
pinched in this fourth turning that we
are in we have to come out of it
resilient and strong as a country and
and there will be some good people uh
who I think will will pay the price but
we cannot allow this moral hazard to
exist where these companies can go focus
on their Dei and their ESG and they they
can induct the new era of cancer culture
through the financials it's going to be
very interesting to be a fly on the wall
at your conference because they're going
to come and make a presentation to the
conference they're going to show and
they're going to show they're going to
show the contagion spreading and they're
going to sit there go guys I know you're
not going to like it but we got to
saddle up and we don't everybody's got
to vote for it because you don't you're
going to make everybody else look bad
this is the pressure you're going to get
I think Andrew Yang called for it didn't
he I'm pretty sure he tweeted the
federal government should backstop best
movie Bill Ackman already did Bill
ackman's Bill the hedge fund Bill Eggman
already said if there's not a deal with
another bank over the weekend we have to
begin the process of a federal bailout
immediately yeah Andrew Yang's tweeted
in the absence of some kind of action
you'll see thousands of mass layoffs and
defunct companies a wiped out generation
of startups each problem in California
in particular and spreading Financial
contagion that will infect a host of
regional banks at a minimum
get ready Monday because that's going to
be everything on TV and they're going to
be calling you guys back there was a
startup bubble because of the coven
policies I don't think people
's belief
we're all going to live in our pods eat
the bugs and you know have doordash
delivered their food read it again from
the top that's exactly this is summer
Yang summary I said perfectly in the
absence of some kind of action you'll
see thousands of mass layoffs and
defunct companies a wiped out generation
of startups huge problems in California
in particular and a spreading Financial
contagion that will infect a host of
regional banks at minimum I'd just like
to add the the you know he says that and
I'm sort of feeling worried until he
says huge problems in California in
particular and I'm like ah
a generation
a generation a generation of tech
companies contagion spread it's all the
The Narrative those are the those are
the building blocks of the narrative and
they're going to work it all weekend the
Sunday shows are going to all be about
this it's not going to be about the
financial policies of Joe Biden and
Powell and these radicals and
incompetence that cause the collapse of
of Silicon Valley Bank because that's
what caused it there'll be nothing about
that it'll all be about how we have to
step in and bail this thing out thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time